[Music]
it's the end of a [ __ ] era guys we
can all take a knee and collectively be
a little bit sad right now because
the official wizard of new zealand
what the [ __ ] is this wait new zealand
has a wizard official the official one
california doesn't have an official one
i'm not doing it right i think we should
we got warlocks the of the ku klux klan
or whatever the official those are
wizards warlocks
oh yeah they are wizards
they're called wizards or head warlocks
right yeah warlocks is part of kkk huh i
didn't know i thought it was just
wizards warlocks and wizards definitely
wizards learned something new uh so the
unfortunately the official wizard of new
zealand perhaps the only state appointed
wizard in the world wow has now been
removed from the public oh
payroll which is the end of a 23-year
legacy in which he was this
[ __ ] wizard was on public
payroll for being a wizard what's his
job that's wizardry that's [ __ ]
magical was it blessing [ __ ] was he
missing [ __ ] what the did they import
him that was on public payroll oh that's
very gandalf oh yeah very good it is
based off of war of the rings no they
got the british flag though huh the
british flag no new zealand no but look
at their flags is that the australian
flag it's the same i think they they
they like they like the uk a lot that's
the union jack
fans of the uk they're real big fans i
think that's a funny way to say it but
sure
don't see him again he looks so happy i
wonder if that's before or after
retirement
this is one back when he had a talisman
he had to sell that recently oh [ __ ] why
is he got a witch hat
i don't like wizard hat dude
it's a wizard hat what's his
responsibility that's what i'm saying
why do you ask that part is someone else
getting appointed
uh no there will not be there will not
be a fulfillment it's a one-off first
and last his name is ian breckenberry
channel ian he's 88 years old well his
last name is channel he's good for 88.
um he had been contracted to christ
church city council for the past two
decades to promote the city through
quote acts of wizardry and other
wizard-like services at the cost of 16
g's a year
he has been paid a total of 370 000 wow
wait let me let me do
let me just clarify the church
paid for him to be no no no
no this the city's name is called church
christ church of wizardry what the
council paid him to the council it's not
a church dude this that's the name of
the city christ church yeah thank you
thank you joe okay that's not confusing
but cool
so
um
the wizard was born in england he began
performing acts of wizardry and
entertainment in public spaces shortly
after arriving in new zealand in 1976
when the council originally tried to
stop him the public protested they liked
it
in 1982 the new zealand art gallery
directors association said he had become
a living work of art and then in 1990
the prime minister at the time mike
moore
demanded that he become
oh
wizard demanded
new zealand oh wow what what kind of
wizard tricks does he do great there's a
couple things he's got the three
styrofoam red balls that like
he hides up in his thumb and his fake
thumb that just puts it in here a magic
trick yeah so one thing that he does um
he performs in christ church
which is a city
he rained danced in new zealand and
australia during droughts and was
awarded the queen's service medal in the
2009's queen's birthday honors
to rain dance did when he rained danced
did it rain following
it did not rain afterwards
this month we got 370 thousand dollars
that's what i'm saying we're all not
making it work it didn't rain
immediately after but it did rain
afterwards three months later it was
like a little while later but everyone's
like hey he did a good job during summer
but it did during like winter but he
told everybody he's like it's gonna take
some time but it will rain and he was
right he was right he was exactly right
um so yeah then um
in april they had a screening of this uh
the show and the wizard said he liked to
he on the show that he liked to tease
women by telling them they're devious
and said quote they use cunning to get
men who are thick
proceeded to say i love women i forgive
them all the time i never struck one yet
never strike a woman because they bruise
too easily
is the first thing
tell their neighbors and their friends
and then
you're in some big dreams
mark did he have that job
do you think this dude was it was
written
do you think he was like getting a lot
of chick's phone numbers from having
this i mean he might maybe witches
which is yeah definitely wishes
is crushing it this is for sure doing
some sort of wizardry because i don't
get it so after this interview
after this interview the council said
they they sent the wizard a letter and
thanked him for all the years of service
they fired him and then they let another
they were no longer going to be renewing
his contract
because because of this because what
happened here what do you say here yeah
i mean the dude's 88 though he didn't
curse them he could put a spell on them
that's all right the grand wizard you
know
that's his way
you can find me you're
that's funny though that's like
i think we should have turned them all
into ice statues or something i'm gonna
make sure it rains for 10 years only on
your house
that's a good little curse
so he's saying
he he clap back i have to say oh he says
that um
he he understands that he doesn't fit
the vibes of the city
it does say that you can
see right here um he said that he's a
provocateur and he says quote implies
that i am boring and old but there's
nobody else anything like me in christ
church it's just they don't like me
because they're boring old bureaucrats
and everyone likes me and no one likes
them that's literally what he said
what a narcissistic way to get out of
there
sassy
everyone likes me but not you you old
your recruiter you're boring all
bureaucrats and everyone likes me and
nobody likes you that is insane guardian
leviosa
but he doesn't do anything
he entertains yeah
and he makes it rain
i'm just saying he didn't demand him i
mean the city loves him he's a movement
he's like um he's like the lovely pigeon
that everyone likes you know like
he's like the park cat you know like
that job he won his job and when they
ditched him everyone got pissed oh and
they said that there's there's kind of a
hornet's nest that's been awakened oh
and that quote the next few months are
going to be real fun or interesting i
mean they're going to start protesting
probably or he's going to [ __ ] make
it rain or he's going to just do a bunch
of curses he was a regular like every
time they had an event he the wizard of
oz
was there it was like a big thing
new zealand's an interesting place you
know what i'm saying they paid
that's kind of like paying the
the village drunk to entertain everybody
yeah i'm with it we should our version
of that
are you not enter the most entertained
by the village drunk of course you are
yeah
right we should take care of them
they're a national monument so i'm
saying we should we should give them a
drink man
jack's off on the street corner and
pukes on his own penis and then goes to
sleep
that's one of the funniest things i've
ever seen yeah that's what i'm saying
give him a [ __ ] salary you know yeah
like yearly salary 16 000 your face so
close to your penis and then puke and
then choking and puking on it but you're
not having your penis in your mouth oh
my god the irony is
it's gross wait you're still choking on
your penis when it's not in your mouth
no he just choked without it in his
mouth got it that's why it's ironic yes
yes
i wish i wish our government did
something like that just like pay people
for being who they are like you're a
wizard you stay a [ __ ] wizard we're
going to support your wizardry do that
that wouldn't fly out here though i
don't think no we're like we just want
to pay you to work in the government not
really do anything yeah don't we we burn
a lot of tax dollars we do like we like
build railroads and train systems that
don't ever get used and like we do i
mean yo that's a lot of money right
there that people can use
especially to pay a salary of like a
mascot like a grand wizard for each
state oh that's true we need a wizard at
the
dmv design shorter
or make it more fun make it more fun
yeah entertain us while we're alive
train dance or something yeah oh yeah
rain dance
that'll let that'll make the line
scatter because it'll rain and the
people who don't want to be in the rain
out here in l.a at the indoor dmv damn
we don't but now they don't let you wait
inside yeah it's all outdoors yeah way
outside you know
sucks oh [ __ ] you know how they have
that don't you wait outside and then you
go inside to wait in another line yeah
yeah yeah okay yeah but dude imagine how
everyone drives so much slower when it
rains in la if you ran in the dmv it'd
be so much slower yeah that's true you
should be even slower
damn man
it's on the piano we need to have that
guy
what more has a piano with it yeah
there's a guy there's usually someone
performing it like glendale galleria or
some [ __ ] and that's why that's and you
do that and then you have one at the dmv
just to get better ambiance that's the
smiles see then if we have it at the dmv
somebody's gonna be like can you play
two shorts
you know you better be ready for what
city they're in exactly there we go i
like that they need to cover the piano
when the professional's not on it though
because i've had i've heard some [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah because then someone just like
is in the middle of shopping and they
want to be discovered no worse like some
seven-year-old kid played chopsticks
yeah
and then it reverberates with the whole
mall bounces through every wall of the
mall for miles bro yeah [ __ ] that dude
let's lock that kid up
don't blame the kid let's beat up the
parents yeah i'm down here i'm down
in new zealand new zealand dude get out
of here watch we hear that at the mall
it's taika and bart's just standing
there going yay
the most beautiful music he's ever heard
and it's [ __ ] not even good
chopsticks
their lucky type is cute though
[Music]
wow